[Music]
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird
and we search for the meaning of life
along the way presented by cast media
and soul pancake
[Applause]
[Music]
hey there i'm reza aslan and i'm rain
wilson and today we're going to talk
about bombs
no no no we're not we're not talking
about bombs so bombs
were apparently invented by robert
oppenheimer
that's fascinating but that's not an
actual topic what's
really interesting is that raza please
that
atomic bombs have only been used twice
in a war i'm just going to pretend that
my co-host reign is having an aneurysm
uh because he apparently can't remember
uh the topic of today's conversation
so bombs get their energy from fission
reactions
do you understand you're ruining the
podcast okay you are ruining
the podcast right okay just like you
ruin everything frankly
you're accusing me of ruining everything
i'm just saying
i mean maybe you don't ruin everything
you ruin
everything you ruin a lot of things
ruining
that's a way better topic than bombs why
do we ruin everything
why do we ruin why do we [ __ ] up every
last
bloomin thing human beings this is a
question that i
ask myself all the time raza why do you
have to [ __ ] everything up
it's a condition that i would say like
most of humanity i would say all of
society
has this condition like this need to
just ruin
everything every good idea we have well
it's been happening since the dawn of
time but
especially it goes hand in hand with
technology
don't you think yeah all of these
innovations wonderful innovations you
got electricity
right we're so happy for electricity it
gets light and heat
and warmth to billions and yet we can
also use it in an electric chair
right i am i'm thinking about that first
you know that first ape that grabbed
that rock and was like hey i can open
this
i can open a coconut with this rock i
can also open a skull
with this rock like this just who we are
we ruin
things so why do we ruin things reza
well look i mean i think part of it has
to do with the fact that we don't really
we don't tend to think about the
implications or the full
consequences of our actions or our
creations you know our innovations we're
so excited about
the next new thing right and how it's
gonna
change the world it's gonna change
everything
and then we never really stop to say
wait what for
better or for worse because it's usually
for worse i think i think that's part of
it we just don't
think far enough well frequently used
example but i'm gonna go there
is this little pocket computer
that i have uh called an iphone if you
had said
to young rayne wilson uh 20 years ago
hey uh you can have a little
a computer in your pocket and in it you
will have all your photographs you've
ever taken
in it you will have unlimited supply of
songs any song
you ever want to hear um you want to
hear ziggy stardust
uh in in three and a half seconds you
can pull that up
you can google anything any piece of
information you want to know
there's endless supply of games uh
people can be in touch with you there's
maps you will never get lost again
you'll never be alone again
i'll never be alone at all i would say
bring it on oh my god this is the answer
to all of my problems
right here in my pocket and yet who
would have foreseen
how addicted i am to this phone and that
i have
seven hours of screen time a day reza
check your screen time seven hours a day
i'm telling you that's so it's so true
like i remember the
the smartphone i was thinking to myself
wow like so you'll never
be bored again because you always have
everything at your
at your disposal and now besides the
fact that it's hard to actually maintain
you know my actual human relationships
because
my phone is with me at all times um
i'm bored now like i have literally like
really
only a million songs is that it no
there's nothing else on here but also
what's wrong with boredom
boredom was not something that we needed
to fix there used to be times when i
would like
be alone with my thoughts wow
i i honestly can't remember i really
can't remember the last time i was alone
with my thoughts because my [ __ ]
phone is with me i thought that today i
literally
meditation is an important part of my
life i went to meditate
and i had my phone as a timer and i had
my phone with me like why do i have
my flippin phone with me when i'm
meditating
i want to meditate i want to commune
with the spirit of the universe
i don't need my phone to tell me that
it's
my move now in a chess game with my
friend wade
i mean we could look we could come up
with a thousand examples of like
things that were created or ideas that
were advanced or
innovations that were developed that
you know were to make things better
right it was make the world better
and it ended up making everything worse
i mean
yes the phone that's a good one internet
absolutely social media
i mean i i guess you and i are old
enough to remember a time
not that long ago where there wasn't
twitter right where facebook didn't
exist
and then it showed up and we were like
wow this is amazing i mean i remember
when when
twitter showed up and i was like so
you're telling me
that i can tell everyone in the world
what i
am thinking at any time
and then you know what happened i
started telling everyone in the world
what i was thinking
at any time well look this is a this is
a fascinating
topic it's something that obviously you
and i have a lot of personal
uh you know involvement in why do we
ruin
everything and i think i think we might
have the right person
to help us answer this question
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen um we have um
[Music]
a writer uh apparently he's published a
few books
uh on the show today um on metaphysical
milkshake
uh malcolm glad well sounds like a made
up name
to me anyways big fan of all of those
books you wrote for economics
sapiens you're the best um no no no
no no dude rain welcome to the what
no it's a wrong guy malcolm gladwell
he wrote tipping point blink david and
goliath eat pray love
all of them huge huge international
bestsellers
i loved eat pray love it made me cry
it's so beautiful you know
for the longest time people legit
thought i did write for economics back
when free economics was that massive
international bestseller at least half
of the people who had come up
and talked to me you know hey you're
mocking level yeah i love freakonomics
and they would go on and on for like you
know they're going people
in that situation go on for like 10
minutes and you don't have a chance to
interrupt and say no no i'm sorry and
then you realize you can't interrupt and
say
no no and finally my strategy was just i
would just say yeah it's you know thank
you so much
really that's it was a great book i
enjoyed writing it i'm now working on
you know for economics too weird like
rain gets that with tom cruise all the
time people are always like
i love the mission impossible movies but
there are there's periods of time as an
actor that i go through where i
get legit recognized as someone else
in another movie for years it was
vincent
vincent d'onofrio and men in black who
remember he played that kind of
lumbering
alien walking down the street um
and there is a certain resemblance there
and it was just
all the time loved you love your work
great it was so funny
the alien men in black and i did the
same thing it's kind of like
thank you thank you obviously we're just
ribbing you we know
all about malcolm gladwell and uh all
the stuff that you do
the revisionist history podcast the
amazing books and of course
your uh newest book uh bomber mafia
which actually happens to be my favorite
of your books i
i really really loved this thing i was
listening to it
on soundcloud and uh you know just kind
of basically
ignoring my children for the last two or
three days just getting so
deep into and he has seven children
that's a heart that's a heart i have to
have
seven seven correct seven children we'll
see how it goes
um which who makes the cut in other
words um
but i love this book it's actually i
have to say of all
of your books it's the one that i found
to be
um most like a history book right i mean
it was like a deep
dive into a particular moment in time
in the second world war it looks at this
huge technological innovation during
that war that
you know could have massively reduced
the number of war casualties
uh but didn't because we managed to [ __ ]
it up so we're going to talk a little
bit more about uh all the themes and
issues that arise from the book but
maybe just for our listeners tell us
who exactly were the bomber mafia so
there's a
group of pilots in the 1930s
uh who were all at a place called
maxwell field which is now maxwell air
force base
just outside of montgomery alabama and
they're
you know this is the dawn of the age of
air power so
planes have only been around for you
know 20 years
um brand new technology no one's really
figured out what they mean
if you want to fight a war they're just
a kind of play thing
and this group of these these guys are
all young they're in their 20s and early
30s and they're
way off the reservation they no one else
involved in the us army
or the navy or any other part of the
marines
thinks these people are sane they think
they're all nuts
and you know they're not in washington
dc and they're not in california not
they're in the they're outside of
montgomery alabama right in the
sleepiest
and they're just they they kind of get
together and
drink a lot of bourbon and they have
this dream
they decide we don't think the airplane
is this
novelty we think the airplane is going
to change warfare forever and
we're going to be the ones to do it and
so they call themselves the bomber mafia
because they
have this dream and in 1936
they had a little school at maxwell air
force base 36 37 38 39
years before the war and not a lot of
people went through that school but
the people who graduated from the school
run by the bomber mafia
were the ones who you could argue they
were the ones who won the war for the
allies i mean everyone who was anyone in
the
air force during the second world war
spent time
[Music]
drinking the kool-aid in central alabama
i mean it's a crazy forgotten
story from the second world war so one
of the things i loved about bomber mafia
was
the incredible cast of characters that
you painted
um there at the training facility
throughout the army um
uh the and the air then this this
burgeoning
air force this kind of nascent air force
which was
so brand new um and two of the greatest
characters were
hayward haywood hansel and curtis lemay
and the thing i was interested about was
that hansel was uh
the one who was really uh
part of the bomber mafia and he was like
the godfather of the bomber mafia right
he was like
yeah and and searching for this goal of
precision bombing that if we can bomb
the exact right target in the exact
right way and the exact right day
we can cause incredible reverberations
throughout the the enemies army and
production
and industry and and bring it to a
screeching halt
and this way we save lives
and uh reduce the time of the war it's
like win win
win all around so this uh a handful of
people come up with this idea
later you get into sorry spoiler alert
but
because we're diving into the ideas
underneath what you've written
um curtis lemay is a you know
trained in the same place but has a very
different philosophy
that maybe you can explain a little bit
about curtis lemay and also the
differences between the two because then
i have a
uh a question for you about it yeah so
imagine
here's the best way to think about it
imagine that you're
canada and you would like to defeat the
united states in a war
and you're the head of the canadian air
force um
and you decide the surest way to get
america to give up
and sue for peace is to [ __ ] new york
city
and actually the bomber mafia one of the
exercises they did was this exact thing
how would we bring new york city to its
knees
one approach would be remove all bagels
from it
yes riots in the street anyway one
approach is
you send you know a couple hundred
bombers
and just level manhattan right that's
one approach
that's what the germans were trying to
do to the english uh when
during the blitz right let's just level
london and see if they
give up the other approach would be the
bomber mafia said well actually
what if all we did was take out the
aqueducts
that bring water to new york city so the
aqueduct
there's an aqueduct you can see it from
the air it's
still there by the way it's whatever
back then it would be
six feet wide you know six feet off the
ground
it runs 30 miles 40 50 miles from the
catskills into new york city it brings
a hundred percent of the water to new
york if you take out the aqueduct and
there's no drinking water in new york
how long will new york last i mean it
won't like
i mean that's it right you couldn't go
on so they would say
why would you don't bother leveling an
entire city and killing millions of
people just take out the aqueduct
the same result will happen but you'll
save
you'll spare a million lives um so
that's the
now if you want to do the second route
take out the aqueduct you have to be
able to hit the aqueduct
right and that was incredibly complex
like it's that was incredibly
just almost an impossible feat like you
said yeah so that's
what the what the these cast of
characters down in alabama led by this
guy haywood hansel
they believed you could take out the
aqueduct they were like you know what
everyone else thinks you can't name a
bomb we think you can name a bomb so
well
that all you have to do is take out
maybe take out the aqueduct and then
take out
like a power station take out a couple
of electrical substations
you could maybe kill 20 people
and use maybe 10 bombers and you're done
call it a day new york's new york's
finished
that's the dream but it was an
impossible dream wasn't it
i went and i had dinner with
the chief of staff of the air force um
got him david goldfein
and afterwards we went outside and
he gathered a bunch of his top people
um and we had drinks and we'd have
chatted for two hours one summer night
last summer
and he there was a moment in the
conversation when he said you know
we were on a fort myer um basin just
outside of dc and
there's a there's a street with a row of
gorgeous homes where all the top
military brass live
the head of the joint chiefs the vice
chair of the joint chiefs the head of
the air force
long row of houses overlooking
washington dc it's incredible
and he was saying you know and he walked
me through all the iterations
of aerial warfare he's like in the
second world war you would have sent
this many bombers
and they would have leveled the entire
base with this many
and then he was like you know my father
flew in vietnam and he would have
brought in
and it would have been you know three
whatever it was three
uh bombers and they would have done and
then like in the gulf war we would have
brought in what i like and today we
would have
a single stealth bomber you wouldn't
hear it coming
and it would take out you know the room
in which we're sitting and nothing else
right he's like talk about the evolution
and he was like so
50 years ago or 70 years ago in order to
kill us all around this little
you know where we were chatting you
would have had to kill
you know another 10 or 20 000 people
because you would have bombed the entire
base today we could just take out you
and me
so too but he said the difference is
now the temptation to go to war is so
much greater
so 75 years ago when you thought about
going to war you're like oh my god
to even to do even the smallest thing in
this war i'm gonna have to kill tens of
thousands of people
he's like today you can be you can sit
in the oval office and you can say
i want to take out malcolm and you could
take out malcolm and no one else
so what's stopping you from taking out
malcolm nothing
right there's no collateral damage
you're not going to kill women and
children
you're not going to like take out not
even going to take out my cat
you could find malcolm walking down the
street and just take out malcolm
so what's stopping you from doing that
every single day
with some other person you don't like
nothing
that's the new temptation and so to your
point
is to that's exactly the question these
guys wrestle with
is the new regime where we can hit
whatever we want with
absolute precision is that more moral
than the old
regime and they don't know the answer to
that question and i don't know the
answer to that question
folks cbd isn't about what you feel it's
about what you
don't feel i'm talking about stress i'm
talking about anxiety
pain you know if you're someone like me
uh you know i'm a writer my neck and
and shoulders are always in agony a
little bit of cbd
takes that pain right away my friends
feels is a better way to feel better
it's a premium cbd that will help you
keep your head
clear and feel your best it's hassle
free delivered directly
to your door as you know i'm a
professional mma fighter
and cbd naturally helps reduce
stress anxiety pain and sleeplessness
that was a joke all you got to do is put
a few drops
of fields under your tongue and you'll
feel the difference within minutes
and joining the fields monthly
membership makes your self-care easy
you'll save money on every order
and you can pause or cancel at any time
start feeling better
with feels there's no reason not to
become a member today
by going to feels.com
milkshake and you'll get 50 off your
first order
and free shipping that's f e a l s
dot com slash milkshake go there to
become a member
and get 50 automatically taken off your
first order with free shipping
feels.com milkshake
now if you'll excuse me i'm going to rub
this cbd all over my naked body
support for today's episode comes from
manscaped
uh rain you're a hairy guy i'm a hairy
guy you're two
hairy men we need some pruning reza we
need some pruning
manscaped is the right tool for that
it'll get the job done quickly safely
and hygienically you know
father's day is around the corner and
you are a father of like 17 children
my children never get me anything for
father's day this would be
a good father's day gift kids actually i
don't let them listen to the pot but
okay so here's what you want to do get
20
off plus free shipping with the code
milkshake
at manscaped.com that's 20 off
manscape.com use the code milkshake
it's dad bod season reza time to get
smooth
the brand new lawnmower 4.0 and ultra
smooth package
is the perfect gift for you and the dad
in your life
to complete your grooming game get 20
off plus
free shipping with the code milkshake
at manscaped.com
well and this brings up of course the uh
the topic of this pod and why we wanted
you on uh
which is why must we ruin everything
right why why can't we have nice things
why
as as a as a species to humans have to
just
[ __ ] everything up we have all these
great ideas these
these um moral imperatives whether it's
target bombing or whether it's the
internet and social media
or whether it's just factories in the
industrial revolution whatever it is we
we act in uh
and goodness and in an attempt to make
life
better for humans and what
always seems to happen is that we end up
making things
worse the factories uh destroy the
environment the
internet uh which is supposed to give
freedom
uh to people and let people's voices be
heard very quickly becomes
just another way for tyrants and
autocrats to stifle
any kind of freedom of speech social
media which is just a
cesspool you know was supposed to change
the way that we communicate with each
other
and expand all of our circles to give us
access to new sources of knowledge and
information
and instead all it's done is made our
world smaller and more
siloed what is the thing
about the human condition and this is a
huge part
of the barber mafia what is the thing
about the human condition
that just has to [ __ ] up
every good intention that we have
especially when it comes to these
technological advances
yeah we can't yeah it is super isn't it
interesting like
we can't help ourselves can't have nice
things
the part of this interest me is i think
in part it's because
we're always solving the part of the
problem that's not a problem
expand on that tell me more well so for
example
um google
googling something gives you unlimited
access to all the information you could
possibly want
um before we had google was that a
problem
well no wasn't a problem in
1995 was my life ruined because
i couldn't look up the capital of
thailand in two seconds
no i i could find out the capital of
thailand it just would take me a little
bit longer
but it wasn't i wouldn't have identified
if you'd said to me in 1995
malcolm your life is forever scarred
because you can't find out
bangkok in two seconds i would have said
actually no it's not that's not the
i have problems in my life that's not
one of them so google looks at all the
problems that malcolm has and decides
the one we're going to solve is we're
going to let you look up
bangkok in two seconds like
that's a sort of dumb version but here's
another dumb one but
it's amazing how many uh
i'm a big runner right now the running
world is in tumult because
nike and all the shoe companies have
come up with shoes that makes
everyone run faster way faster so every
record is being broken right now
which has the effect of erasing the past
so now like we don't even know who the
fastest runners are
anymore someone's going to break usain
bolt's 100 meter
record this summer but not because
they're better than usain bolt but
because their shoes are better so now
that solves a problem of
of it helps us run faster but that
wasn't a problem
the problem with running was not that
we're not running fast enough the
problem was
we get injured or the problem is not
enough people run
how about a shoe that helps people who
don't want to run
run that strikes me as a legitimately
good shoe
that's not the shoe we got the shoe we
got was
it helped people who already run like
maniacs to run
a couple seconds faster why are you
solving that problem
that's not the problem right but i feel
like we do endless versions of this
like it's cons like it's just like i
want to convene all the smart people in
the world and say okay guys look
let's just can we just decide on what
the top 10 biggest problems are and
let's just
focus on those for five minutes as
opposed to running off
and like giving me some other like thing
that
someone's right now in the world is
trying to make a bicycle which is one
ounce lighter
why the problem with bicycles
is that when i ride my bicycle i'm
afraid so a car's gonna hit me and kill
me
solve that problem please right
it's just the end but it's just to your
point this is why we can't have nice
things
because all the smart people are not
solving the thing the problems that are
problems
but isn't there something a little a
little deeper isn't there something a
little
underneath that a little bit which is uh
we're so into short-term gain that
uh we don't think things through
and doesn't doesn't there need to be for
instance
let's just use precision bombing um
what it led to is in this kind of war
and against terror that we're in right
now is it i'm not trying to get all
political but
essentially what it's led to is a kind
of non-stop war
and then precision bombing is used as an
assassination
technique so there's a constant kind of
button being pushed oh someone's getting
assassinated oh they got taken out oh
this general got taken out this person
i'd say one step further than that it's
turned war into a video game
so our fighters aren't even necessarily
out
in the battlefield anymore they're in a
cubicle you've seen the guys flying the
drones that
they're this they look like guys playing
an xbox you know what
along these very lines what uh what the
when i was chatting with all those air
force generals they were talking about
the stealth bomber
so the stealth bomber is in i may have
this correct
incorrect it's in um kansas
on an air force base in kansas and it's
in kansas because
it's so valuable costs so much it's got
to be in the center of the [ __ ]
of the country so we can defend it so
when we were fighting the war and i
think in
uh in bosnia or that
the the guys would get in the plane
the drive they live in this suburb of
whatever city in the middle of kansas
they would drive to the air force base
get in the plane
and fly in so fast they would fly to
wherever it was
drop their bombs fly home and then
pick up their kids from school and wow
it's like the whole notion of you know
this you have to go to the field of
battle and you
you're away from your family for months
no no these guys are literally they're
getting in the
ford escape at eight o'clock in the
morning and driving to the air force
base
and they're in they're over europe in
like whatever it is a couple
two hours now they don't even do that
right now they just go to
you know again some like office building
somewhere in virginia yeah
and fly the drone over from there and
pick up papa john's pizza on the way
home
yeah it's we it's so it is so weird
i mean so here's the question i have
malcolm is
has it always been like this i mean
do you feel like there was a time in in
you know human society in which you know
we
actually stopped to think about the
long-term morality
behind these innovations or as rain said
is it just that part of the human
condition is that we can't we don't have
the ability for that kind of long-term
thinking that we're always trying to
solve the problem immediately in front
of us
and we don't stop to think what will be
the consequences
for solving this particular problem i
mean occasionally
we clearly get it right some portion of
the time right that's
that's why we have progressed as a
species
and you and i can point to 10 20
you know the coveted vaccine solves a
problem that's a problem
like we did a really good job on that so
we can get our act together and we can
focus
i just think there's a lot of time spent
on
i remember i don't want to pick on
everyone picks on him but i'm going to
pick on jeff bezos for a moment
somebody asked him why he built this you
know he wants to
build a rocket that goes to wherever it
is mars and
they're like why are you spending
billions of your dollars building a
rocket to go to mars he goes like that
was just the most interesting problem i
could
i could think of trying to solve and i
was like
really dude that's the problem can you
that's how about poverty the most
interesting hunger i don't know
can i borrow 15 minutes of your time to
give you some other suggestions about
where you want to put your billions
although in bezos's uh favor i will say
he's shifted his focus now and he is
putting
tens of billions 60 80 100 billion
dollars towards fighting climate change
which is cool although yeah you know
sidebar
it is causing climate change it's uh
he's you know he's doing this carbon
sequestration
kind of technology like how do we not
cease polluting but actually just take
carbon from the atmosphere and put it
back no that's the better
i'll a bit i thought it was funny that
the minute his
wife mackenzie sets out on her own
she immediately gives away a whole lot
of money for some really really good
causes like i feel like
she was sort of sitting in the back like
thinking she was thinking about it now
jeff there's some better things we could
do with our cash i mean i have an idea
jeff maybe don't send me
one tube of toothpaste at a time
that's that seems like well maybe maybe
reza don't order one tube of toothpaste
at a time
because that's what i do with amazon
toothpaste
here's my mini computer in my pocket
thank you whoever invented that
idea toothpaste and then the next day
it's at my house
but i i want to bring i want to talk
about morality for a minute i know this
is
i know this is it's a it's a difficult
topic but
it's just like forget religion let's put
religion aside let's put the ten
commandments aside and
god and hell and damnation and any of
that nonsense aside
and just talk about like just good
old-fashioned right and wrong
and isn't this a result
why do we [ __ ] things up because
morality is not connected to technology
because when science happened uh
science wanted to be unfettered from
any kind of restraint it just is like we
are just going to
look at data and we're going to uh
create experiments and we're going to
solve problems and we're just going to
build [ __ ]
and there was never that kind of ongoing
discussion of like okay precision
bombing
let's get together let's have a
colloquium let's have a zoom meeting
let's uh bring everyone to the table and
talk about okay
what are the what are the consequences
of precision bombing what might
precision bombing look like in 10
20 50 100 years and how now
can we address that isn't morality at
play in this discussion malcolm
well the you know the original obama
mafia certainly felt
they were representing a moral position
a considered moral position
and i think uh in their context they
were right so
they didn't they weren't thinking about
how the modern world would use some of
the ideas they were proposing and
technologies they were proposing
to turn war into a kind of 24 7
phenomenon they had a legitimate
immediate concern which was
they had just come out of the first
world war which was
you know the first world war is was one
of the most extraordinary moral
abominations of
you know where a million people died in
one battle in the first world war in the
battle of the psalm is crazy
so they were saying we don't need to do
that again we we you know
so i don't think i think what happens
it's not that morality and technology
are disconnected
it's that i think they very often start
connected
and what happens is that they just go on
divergent paths
like i do think the people who started
twitter
you know honestly felt that twitter
could be an agent for
positive change in it could be a way to
fight
tyranny it could do all these you know
remember all the excitement around
twitter and
arab spring people that was an honest
belief that
twitter was a force for good turns out
probably isn't
doesn't have the impact we thought it
would but that's not the fault of
um it's just that we didn't no one had
any notion about how that technology
would evolve
you know we didn't realize that twitter
was just going to turn into high school
he thought it was something nobler and
you know grander
um and so i don't know i think
it's just kind of impossible for anyone
who's at the in on the ground floor of a
technology to understand the way it's
going to evolve the way it's going to
interact with
existing institutions and does it also
have to do with the fact that
innovation moves at such a fast pace
right that it is
sometimes difficult to slow down long
enough to say
what what are the consequences of this
like i mean i remember
the genius of twitter was precisely that
you could be anonymous
and so if you were you know a green
movement
member in tehran
you could be on twitter and anonymously
post information
without you know putting your life at
risk and that same
very important innovation
in 2009 now makes it
you know the worst place on earth uh
where you know
any [ __ ] can say whatever he wants to
say about you know anyone without ever
having to deal with
um the consequences because of of
twitter's anonymity
so in a sense like the issue here is
that
the this in each case the source of our
progress
is also the source of our downfall
and we can't catch up to
the technological innovations because
they're moving at such a rapid pace
um and so it's almost like this this
rock is rolling down the hill
and there's almost nothing to be done
about it one
one technological innovation leads to
the next one leads the next one leads to
the next one
and then next thing you know you know
war is a video game played by teenagers
in inside of you know cubicles and so
what i want you to do because you've
spent 30 years
right delving into aspects of history
and historical trends
and i'm curious when you when you look
at
certainly the last you know 50 years or
so of technological innovation since
since the since the second world war
most definitely
and when you look at the ways in which
we have
used technology or or created technology
meant for good
only to have it turned against us in one
way or another
do you feel like there's
some kind of hope like do you do you see
that this perpetual cycle you know of
being [ __ ] by [ __ ] up uh to put it
in uh
kindly do you see that cycle heading in
the right direction
or are things just going to get worse
especially now with
you know the the current pace of
technological advancement
yeah i mean i'm congenitally
optimistic so i always like to believe
that we figure things
these problems out um i do think you
know
this is a this is a a random example of
this
i was i read this essay on the internet
um by a guy who was doesn't have a lot
of money and was talking about what does
it mean
to be just above the poverty line in
america right
i am not just about the poverty line in
america so a lot of what he was talking
about
is stuff i don't think about and one of
the examples he was talking about was
you know
if you're not on the just above the
poverty line you forget how big a deal
cars are if you are that you're
in fear that your car is going to break
down and if your car breaks down
you're screwed can't get to work you
could lose your job
can't do really really basic things and
you don't have any other options
and the cost of fixing your car is
typically more than you can afford and
it's just talking through that kind of
anxiety and it made me think you know
has anyone designed a car
with that set of things in mind
so you know we we design
um mass transit with that person in mind
but mass transit
in most cities doesn't have that doesn't
actually solve that person's problem
because
you could spend four hours getting to
your job on the other side of la you
know it doesn't help you if you got to
wake up but
you're already stressed out you're
working at four o'clock now to get to
work at eight
but does someone say i can build a car
that not only is
cheap to buy and cheap to run but is
i have ruthlessly removed every source
of potential breaking down
you know that's all i care about that'd
not be fancy doesn't have to be
sort of we've done that but not really
right
like that's a really really useful thing
to kind of
puzzle out but i do i think we'll have
that in
five years i actually kind of think with
some combination of like
electric cars and autonomous thingy and
you know if you add all these together
we could get to a some kind of solution
for that person
um but it's amazing to me how long it's
taken us to get there
right we've been poor people have had
trouble getting to work
for as long as there have been poor
people
and they have you know and like and it's
gotten worse in
contemporary times with you know
inequality and
traffic and all these kinds of things
and like it just it distresses me how
long it's taken but i do have confidence
we'll get there
it's funny you bring that up because as
a kid the first time i ever rode on a
golf cart
i was like why don't we just have golf
carts
why don't we have all these different
cars and trucks and bus like everyone
just give everyone a golf cart and the
first time i was on the bumper cars i
was like
why can't ever why can't anyone everyone
just have a bumper car this is perfect
just bump into each other all the time
we can bump and it doesn't hurt anyone
and you can bump you can have fun
but isn't that where we're headed yeah i
know this is kind of a
tangential but we're kind of headed in
the place where everyone is going to
have the equivalent
of a golf cart bumper car that maybe
yeah okay
maybe its range is a little bit limited
200 miles and maybe it only goes up to
40 or 50 miles an hour
but that's but it doesn't break down it
charges at night it doesn't have
emissions
anyway we'll figure out a way to screw
it up to follow up
so that's actually a really good example
and i know this is a tangent but
it allows you to think about what has to
happen for us to get there
so yes could we have a world where every
car
is essentially very very small
and is a bumper car where
if it if it collides with another they
just kind of bounce off
yes you can get there but the only way
you get have to get there is that rich
people have to give up
their big heavy expensive cars we all
have to agree
if we all agree to ride around on little
tiny
light things then all cars can be
little tiny and light but if one person
says
no i still want to drive my suv then it
doesn't work anymore right because
then everyone else has to defend against
the suv right so you
you get into these these these questions
of solving social problems very very
quickly become
questions about collective morality that
i have to convince the person with the
cadillac escalade
or the range rover you can't have a
range order anymore
right to solve the problem for the guy
who's on the
poverty line you have to give up your
ride
are you willing to give up your ride
right
now we have a now we have a moral now we
have a moral
social complicated problem to solve i
think uh i'm pretty sure malcolm just
figured out the subject of his next new
yorker article
the bumper card bumper cars for all yeah
this was just a fascinating discussion i
got so much
out of it and the the way that you take
history and you intersect it
with life's biggest questions and
psychological and sociological
quandaries
is uh really inspiring and uh and you've
done that again with bomber mafia and
uh it was uh it was just fabulous it's
got my
my mind is is bubbling
[Music]
and speaking of big questions malcolm
you know we like to end our podcast with
what we call the lightning round we just
ask you a bunch of kind of big questions
and then you just
answer the first thing that comes to
your mind and then we snicker and make
fun of you
silently um you ready for that no not
silently after he leaves
what's the one skill you wish you had
wish i could uh swim
you literally can't swim like you sink
to the bottom like a stone
can't swim wow that's great because i
was going to ask my lightning round
question is
what is something no one knows about you
probably that i can't swim
[Laughter]
what emotion do you wish you could
better control
oh my god what an interesting question
well i'm such a repressed englishman
i feel like they're all under control i
would ask the question differently
which emotion do you do you wish you
couldn't control
right which one would you want to let go
let loose
uh well you know i i wish i was
more um emotionally expressive
particularly in my um in my
affections for people you know i wish i
told people who i love that i love them
more i suppose
i would say that you can practice on me
right now
i love you rain name something that a
lot of people like but you can't stand
little mermaid big opponent of the
middle of the little
little mermaid yeah people don't know
this about you malcolm but you've
really got it in for the little mermaid
i have it in the homer man uh
when do you feel most connected to the
universe when i'm running
what's one eye-opening experience that
everyone
should have well i go back to running
everyone should know what it feels like
to run for more than an hour
so to be by yourself in nature
alone with your thoughts in motion for
more than 60 minutes
all right and then finally what is your
life's
big question uh it's a question that my
that i got from my mom which is
every morning i feel like my mother
would ask the question where do i find
joy
in the coming day that's my question
that's a great daily question
here's a funny thing that malcolm will
not remember this story but
before my first book had come out that's
when i first met you malcolm i met you
at a party somewhere
and i remember we're having a
conversation we were having drinks and i
said to you you know i've got a book
coming out
do you have any advice for me and this
is what you said
you said yes
remember nobody gives a [ __ ] about you
or your book except you do you remember
telling me that
i said that no it was eye-opening it was
the
greatest advice i have ever heard i have
literally given that advice to dozens of
more people
you may have a publicist you may have an
editor you may have
you know a marketing machine behind you
you may have
you know an agent and all that stuff
they don't give a [ __ ] about you or your
book
yeah that's what i meant yes that is
true
literally my entire career
was launched from that bit of advice
just do it yourself
because no one else cares it's just you
anyway well malcolm gladwell we've loved
all your books from the power of now
to songs my father taught me to it takes
a village
um my favorite was beloved absolutely
uh genius thank you for all of those
wonderful stories
thank you for your contribution to
western civilization
and thanks for this conversation it was
really fantastic
yeah no my pleasure thank you guys
wow that malcolm gladwell huh how about
kids going places
what a storyteller really really
interesting conversation
and uh you know i was thinking about the
whole bumper car
idea like individual bumper cars and
it's kind of
genius if you think about it like if we
all just had
you know these kind of small bumper cars
like covered in rubber and just kind of
bouncing off each other all the time
there'd be no more
accidents and deaths you know everyone
turns 16 they all get
a bumper car that is never gonna break
down uh
sealed nice little radio in there
protect you from the elements maybe it
just needs a little heater
yeah this could be the future i think
it's so i think it's great what could go
wrong
nothing could go wrong possibly
some [ __ ] is gonna outfit his bumper
car with
even bigger bumpers and then what's
going to happen then i have to have
bigger bumpers obviously like if he's
having bigger bumpers
so you can really slam someone going
down the venture a freeway
you know i i knew i knew that you were
going to figure it out and we've got
gladiator bumper cars
right you saw ben hur the little spikes
sticking out of the side
yeah then ginormous think about that
bumper cars
the size of suvs
i guess the other thing too is we'd have
to put bumpers on all the like the
highways too right because you gotta
bump off the wall
oh that would be something this isn't
gonna work now that i think about it
actually
see we we we ruined it we ruined it yeah
we'll just screw it up
in all seriousness i was really uh
touched
by his optimism and
uh for someone who's written this many
books and has
dovan dived into uh
human psychology and sociology with uh
as much expertise as he has over the
decades
uh he's still optimistic for the future
yeah and the
can-do human attitude that can overcome
these issues so
i enjoyed hearing that about this
conversation it's just us that are the
hopeless cynics reza
it's mostly me let's just be honest it's
you basically
it's you but your wife is so nice is she
available to do a podcast with me
super fun conversation thank you again
to malcolm gladwell
everyone check out his new book slash
audiobook slash
podcast extravaganza storytelling event
the bomber mafia it truly is a
fascinating tale
and now listen maybe you want some more
of the life's big questions you can find
us
on our socials at reza aslan and
at rain wilson also of course at
metaphysical milkshake
let us know your life's questions right
and who knows
we just might explore them on a future
episode you can also subscribe to the
metaphysical milkshake youtube channel
where you can watch
full episodes every week and remember to
follow rate and comment on metaphysical
milkshake on apple podcasts and wherever
else you listen to podcasts
thank you so much for listening today
see you next week in the meantime
try not to ruin everything
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan
and colin thompson it is produced by
safa samazadeh yazd
harris lane mick dimaria hashem self and
dj
lubel cast media is the production and
distribution partner
it is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by justin
kyle original music by jeff tang
[Music]
like my wife is i i love cooking and i
love cooking for my wife
and she's always so grateful for you
know the meals that i make for her
and it makes me feel good until i
realize she likes everything
there's nothing she doesn't like so then
just make her grilled cheese and call it
a day